okay let's talk about voter intimidation
and your rights at the polls you may
have heard that Donald Trump has been
talking about these election monitors
these poll Watchers if you want to make
sure that it's not rigged for Hillary by
mostly Republican state legislators
governors and and voting commissions but
let's put that inconvenient fact aside
for a second you can sign up to help
Trump monitor the polls to make sure
that there's no you know bub
intimidation or the the the the wrong
people voting whatever in any case this
is making a lot of people say over what
what's going to happen when I show up to
vote on november eighth we are expecting
antagonism we are expecting
aggressiveness there are some examples i
want to give you of what you might
experience at the polls questioning
people about citizenship outside of the
polls questioning people about their
criminal record questioning people about
qualifications to vote that is voter
intimidation and you need to know how to
deal with that and i will tell you how
to deal with that up falsely presenting
oneself in a way that makes it seem as
though there's some kind of election
official this is something you need to
be prepared for because there are going
to be legitimate election officials at
the polls but with this cadre of
incompetents that Donald Trump has been
building through a website sign up form
you're going to see people that are not
officially involved with the election in
any way that are going to be there may
be intimidating may be aggressive uh if
anybody is walking around voting lines
spreading false info information like
for example hey you have to be able to
speak English to vote but that's not
true or here's the document you need to
vote when it may not actually be true in
a particular state you're voting in or
displaying signs that are false or
misleading about voter fraud all of
these activities fall under voter
intimidation and you need to know how to
deal with it so first of all who can you
report this to okay let's start there
number one you can report voter
intimidation to the election protection
hotline 866 our vote you can also call
the US Department of Justice voting
rights hotline 800 253 3931 and you can
also talk to your local and state
officials this includes poll worker
this includes the County Clerk etc Pat
do you think people in general are
equipped and they know what to do or who
to call I think most people don't people
will show up and they'll say that
doesn't look right but they won't
actually be equipped with who to call or
what to do so I think this is really
important yet for the most part this
intimidation tactic could work and we
know that the Republican Party has a
history of this in 1981 they got in
trouble for sending off-duty police
officers who intimidate people that were
voting in the New Jersey gubernatorial
election yeah that that's one very
specific example but many more so who
could actually be a poll monitor you
might show up and see people claiming
that they are election officials poll
monitors there to make sure everything
is on the up-and-up it depends on the
state but in many states you actually
have to be trained and certified and
have paperwork with you and in many
states you also have to be registered to
vote in the location you were monitoring
so a few different things to be aware of
if you were not on the list of
registered voters when you show up and
you believe that you should be if they
can't find you you asked for a
provisional ballot every voter is
entitled to a provisional ballot even if
you are not showing up in the registered
book and in the days after the election
in principle that is a vote that is
going to be counted if you're indeed
authorized to vote number two there
cannot be campaigning at polling places
as a general thing inside and then the
laws vary from state to state in terms
of what is allowed outside and how far
you have to be you can campaign a
certain number of feet from the front
door type of thing and I've experienced
that uh many many times the important
thing is do not allow yourself to be
scared into not voting know your rights
have the numbers written down that I
mentioned you can go back and if you're
watching this video on youtube or check
out the clip on youtube and also you are
able to involve local police if
necessary don't forget that at any point
you can call local police if you believe
that you have been intimidated that
there is an aggressive uh non non
authorized in many cases a poll watcher
know your rights know what you have to
do the ACLU has a very very good and
sense of right up on this because there
are going to be at least in some states
these Trump supporting poll Watchers
they're too intimidated we've got to
make sure that every voter actually has
their vote that is able to cast their
vote and that the votes are counted I
keep getting emails from people saying
David whatever it is that you're talking
about on your show about this upcoming
election it doesn't matter because I
know who is ultimately going to win and
to all of these people I say well it's
great that you're so confident why don't
you actually bet on it then you can go
to bed d si.com where you can bet on
Hillary Hillary Clinton versus Donald
Trump you can bet on state by state
election results in so many other areas
and if you use coupon code Pakman 25
once again that's PA que ma and 25
you'll get $25 free towards an election
play and you know on november nine
everybody's going to be saying oh I knew
X was going to happen uh if you really
that sure you can actually make some
money off of it this is like when
psychics claim to be real and I always
say well if that's the case you can use
that to your advantage and show us that
you actually know the future along the
same lines you should see my twitter
feed my facebook feed youtube email
people seem to think that they are
psychic with regard to this election and
to you I say head over to bet d si.com
which has been in business more than 20
years use code Pakman 25 to get a free
$25 bonus for bedding and make some cash
with your incredibly accurate
predictions that you claim you can make